la vidéo amateur a été filmée quelques
secondes seulement après la frappe et
voici ce qu'il reste de ce populaire
restaurant de pizzas
il est situé à cramatork seul grande
ville de l'est de l'Ukraine encore
contrôlée par Kiev
mardi ici la foule était compacte
lorsque deux missiles russes ont semé la
terreur
je ne me souviens de rien j'ai juste vu
un éclair il y avait beaucoup de monde
vous devriez partir il y aura un autre
missile
filmé par un drone à la nuit tombée ces
images permettent aussi de bien se
rendre compte de la violence de la
déflagration
toute la nuit les équipes de secours se
sont affairés pour tenter de retrouver
des survivants sous les gravats
tous les services de l'État sont
mobilisés les urgences la police
l'équipe paramédicale l'administration
militaire nous avons aussi mis sur pied
un centre de crise
accusé par Kiev d’être responsable de
cette frappe Moscou ni en bloc
la Fédération de Russie ne frappe pas
les infrastructures civiles
sur des cibles qui sont d'une manière ou
d'une autre liées à l'infrastructure
militaire
à cramator les recherches poursuivaient
encore ce mercredi au milieu des tôles
froissés par l'explosion